isn't lizzle like the nicest person in
the world
look what she sent me lizzo is sending
cardi b
all her love oh yes honey on tuesday the
[ __ ] rapper hit up her insta story to
thank
lizzo for sending her a bouquet of
flowers isn't lizzle like the nicest
person
in the world look what she sent me she
is just a beautiful ass person i just
love her
so much these are so pretty the grammy
winner
even sent a handwritten note people
quote flowers for a flower congrats on
all your success this summer
know you are loved and our love p.s i'm
sending you something good this week
love lizzo um cute i'm feeling good in
town
the sweet gesture from lizzo comes after
cardi opened up about the truth hurts
singer during a hot 97 interview
earlier this month where cardi revealed
that she wanted to include
lizzo in the [ __ ] music video i'm cool
with lizzle and everything like we be
sending
uh dms to each other and all that but um
i think she was on vacation so she
wasn't in town but i was like oh my gosh
because i had a whole vision of how i
wanted to see little and everything
the generous gift also comes after the
27 year old filed for divorce from
offset her husband of three years on
tuesday in
atlanta according to court docs obtained
by tmz
the rapper shared that there are no
prospects for a reconciliation
cardi's divorce filing comes after she
opened up an l magazine's september
issue about how solid their relationship
was
noting that while it has a lot of drama
there's also
a lot of love passion trust and a big
friendship
cardian offset tied the knot in
september 2017
but they kept their marriage a secret
until the following june
the couple's daughter culture was born
one month later in july 2018.
i just want to show people how beautiful
and how precious she is she's so
precious
seriously of course the couple has had
their fair share of ups and downs over
the years
in december 2018 cardi revealed the two
split up on instagram
and two months later she opened up to
e.t about trying to keep her family
together
working it out yeah taking it slow
yeah we can see the family back together
i mean we always gonna be
a family that's together yeah my baby
love us both and we just wanna
you know it's like like having a baby
that like the
whole world wants to see and watch and
know
you just have to be very overly
protective
and that's something that we always
gotta like
make sure we always keep communication
and
special care and make sure that we
um see our schedule is so crazy and it's
just like spending time
these are the times that the babies like
you know they recognize their parents
they want to be close to their parents
all the time